and as we've reported here on channel 8
abortions are still legal here in nevada
up to 24 weeks it would take a vote of
the people to remove that protection
regardless rallies continue locally in
support of abortion rights madison
kimbrough stopped by one event held
earlier tonight
planned parenthood coming together with
the community to host their week of
action community care event as they want
it known that planned parenthood will
continue to support women from all over
and give them the access to health care
they need at monday's gathering abortion
care kits were provided and messages of
support written out in chalk on the
sidewalks at desert breeze park dozens
of attendees many of which were parents
shared the impact this decision has had
on their families along with those who
are still in disbelief that our country
is going through this in 2022 top
priority would be to
represent
my daughter's generation there shouldn't
be any
male figure to dictate what a woman does
with their body and that's where i find
out because frankly we don't know what's
going on
with their bodies when i was younger and
growing up
the roe v wade had just passed
and i was so proud that i lived in a
country
and now
it's like they've taken it away from us
and i never felt in my lifetime that
they would reverse it planned
parenthood's week of action continues
with several virtual events
as well as an in-person celebration of
abortion access in nevada rally taking
place this friday at the erotic heritage
museum at 6 pm mata